you are also raising chickens the last
time I saw you how are the chickens okay
this is a weird thing to say but they
were a rental what yeah
because when I got the chickens I was
like I'll just be this kind of person
who's like hey I'm I'm earthy I have
chicken but really my husband was like
you're not gonna want these chickens for
very long and there was a guy near us we
live in Massachusetts most of the year
and he rents chickens kind of like why
not Memorial Day to Labor Day and um
yeah interesting we got rid of those
girls they um they were really hard
those hens were hard to handle okay
those hens were following my husband
around everywhere and I was like I
almost got a little bit jealous
like they didn't want to have anything
to do with me and they just followed my
husband around and then did you like
having eggs though that's kind of cool
here's the thing oh we're getting we're
getting like one egg every four days
what they just were weird and they slept
on the top of their lazy chickens yeah
chickens pop them out girls what the
hell I want some eggs I want some eggs
yeah you probably had no ticks in the
bag right oh I wish I mean not to Lazy
chicken I know not to be a bummer but
yeah it's a got a big tick problem in
Massachusetts well the Northeast yeah in
Texas as well where I'm from yeah yeah
yeah yeah well have you ever had any
chickens I know everybody's like chicken
did you see I just did yeah everyone is
yeah have you ever had any like not odd
animals but farm animals or anything
like that and then like dog or cat I've
had a horse okay he was very important
to me I met him making a film in Mexico
I I we bonded we I had I couldn't say
goodbye so I had him sent from Durango
to pass Juarez to El Paso he got on a
FedEx and he flew into New York City a
horse flew FedEx that's the easiest way
to get him there we'll deliver
everything correct yeah they will and
and he was a great companion to my
oldest son who has an intellectual
disability he's autistic and so even if
he didn't want to ride you could give
him a brush and a bucket and you know
they're both happy all afternoon no it's
very therapeutic they do
yeah
yeah absolutely yeah that's
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I'm going
[Music]